6 Minute English from the BBC
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English.
I'm Neil. And I'm Phil.
Oh, what's that awful noise, Phil?
Sorry, Neil. I was biting my nails.
I know it's a bad habit.
Oh, it sounds terrible.
Sorry, Neil. Actually, it's not only you who find certain sounds irritating,
unpleasant, or even unbearable.
Whether it's someone biting their nails,
rustling a crisp bag, or scraping a knife on a dinner plate.
Some everyday sounds have the power to make us angry or upset.
There's even a name for it,
misophonia, also known as sound rage.
And it's more common than you might think.
According to some estimates, one person in five is affected emotionally by the coughing,
slurping, sneezing, and snorting sounds made by the people around them.
In this programme, we'll be finding out more about the medical condition
misophonia, and as usual, we'll be learning some useful new vocabulary as well.
But first, I have a question for you, Phil.
According to a recent survey by the American Journal Medical News,
which of the following did their readers find the most unpleasant sound?
Is it a bicycle brakes squeaking?
B. Nails scraping a blackboard, or C. A baby crying?
I guess it was squeaky bicycle brakes.
I really hate that.
Okay, Phil. We'll find out the answer later in the programme.
For people suffering from misophonia, the specific sounds which cause them to become
emotionally upset, also known as triggers, often involve food and eating.
Just sitting down for dinner with their family can feel like torture.
Alana Tanzley-Hankock is a British clinical researcher who also suffers from misophonia.
Here she explains some of her triggers to BBC World Service programme, the food chain.
It's just any kind of inescapable repetitive noise,
we'll potentially cause a mesophonic type response in me that fight off-light,
and yet it's that immediate uncontrollable reaction that you get to the sound,
that is the most hard to explain and unusual, I think, because I don't think in modern day,
you don't really get many instances where you get a fight of flight responses,
not like we're frequently chased down by wild animals, and then to fill those from
pretty innocuous everyday sounds is the thing that takes its toll.
Certain sounds trigger a fight or flight response in Alana,
fight or flight refers to the way the human body responds to stressful or dangerous situations,
either by physically running away or staying to deal with the threat.
Normally these would be life-threatening dangers, things like a fire or an attacking wild animal,
but for mesophonia sufferers even innocuous or completely harmless sounds create problems.
That's right, Alana, for example, gets disturbed by helicopters flying in
the sky, and the fact that other people don't seem to bother it also takes its toll,
a phrase meaning causes suffering or pain. So what does it feel like to actually experience this
kind of stress in everyday life? Here's Alana again explaining her feelings to Ruth Alexander,
presenter of BBC World Service Program, The Food Chain.
It's not the same feeling, but it's the same response in terms of the immediacy and
inability to control it, as when someone tells you that someone close to you has passed away.
That feeling of utter sudden reaction, you can't control it, and then it lingers and carries on
for you. That immediate emotional response. Almost like a shock to the system.
Yeah.
Alana describes her misophonia as an uncontrollable and sudden emotional reaction,
as if finding out that a loved one has passed away.
Passed away is a polite euphemistic way of saying, died. She also describes it as a shock to the
system, a sudden and unpleasant change. Fortunately, mesophonia sufferers have developed some tricks
to help. Playing background music can disguise the sound of people sipping and slurping their food,
and clearly, honestly explaining what the condition is also helps people sympathise and understand.
But of course, some sounds simply are disturbing. For example, you biting your nails, Phil.
Okay, okay, I said I was sorry. Maybe it's time to reveal the answer to your question, Neil,
before you get more upset. You asked me which sound was voted the most irritating for
readers of the journal medical news. Right, and you guessed it was Bicycle Brakes squeaking,
which was the wrong answer I'm afraid, Phil. In fact, nails scraping a blackboard was voted the
most distressing noise, and I completely agree. Right, let's recap the vocabulary we've learned
from this program on misophonia, starting with trigger, something that causes people to feel
emotional distress or fear. Fight or flight refers to the natural human response to a threatening
situation of either running away or staying to face the danger. The adjective innocuous means
completely harmless. If something takes its toll, it causes suffering, damage or death.
Past away is a polite way of saying died. And finally, the phrase a shock to the system
means a sudden and unpleasant change. Once again, ask six minutes to wrap. Join us again next time
for more trending topics in use of the vocabulary. Here at six minute English. Goodbye for now. Goodbye.